The best way to get the optimum results out of your day is to plan your day the night before.
There are two reasons for this.
Too often during the day,...
...we're just responding to everyone else's needs instead of doing our intended plan.
So if you don't have a plan, you're guaranteed not to be doing what you wanna do.
You'll be responding to other people.
The second reason for planning your day the night before...
...is you can rationally decide what you're going to do at what time of the day.
Too often, people just work from a to-do list.
What you want is to schedule exactly what you're gonna do at what time.
Schedule how long you think it's gonna take.
And by doing it the night before, here's the payoff:...
...all night long, your unconscious and subconscious mind...
...is going to be working on how to make that happen.
It's going to be coming up with creative ideas,...
...pulling information from your past memory into the present so you can utilize it,...
...and literally planning your perfect day.
It's like having an employee working for you all night long.
If you do it in the morning, you don't get that benefit.
And then, start to work your plan.
Plan your life.
Work your plan.
You're gonna be very, very successful.